[Music]
we have some really
worrying cases in Europe, one of these is
the case of Salvini and the story of the
alleged Russian loans that
were at the center of a
judicial investigation of a
journalistic investigation that involved
international newspapers affaire with
analytical bridge f o di  finans world rally with
the cloths affaire escapes un tris affaire
of bon crisis as a background signal from
you and all from three years of school that
another democracies terme ablo use
extranjera put in place risks
claims fund agreements and at times they are
new climbs to  old pistons and the
postman museum or lucio schiavon and my
cousin skins
facebook is huge boundaries of the night
because block delegations to facebook and
twitter the chance of the world democracy
is worth more are more leagues and
according to paolo de falco customers
we must be ready to react to
defend our democracy to
defend our freedoms from those who want to
subvert those who want to manipulate the
our future
iago sul paolo deindustrie women in
front of was with soir to we found the
fight with facebook I was what
breakfast 1
[Music]